IBM and equinex the White House cyber
security plan and recognition for Q
radar Sim all on this episode of IBM
Tech now what's up y'all my name is Ian
and I am back to bring you the latest
and greatest news and announcements
about IBM technology to kick things off
this week we are thrilled to announce a
technology collaboration between IBM and
equinex this collab will enable IBM
hybrid Cloud mesh customers to deploy
the upcoming hybrid Cloud mesh gateways
on the equinix metal platform IBM hybrid
Cloud mesh is a SAS offering designed to
enable Enterprises to bring management
to their hybrid multicloud
infrastructure it will allow devops and
Cloud Ops teams to collaborate to
seamlessly manage and scale Network
applications across a wide variety of
public and private clouds Edge and on
premises
environments driven by application
Centric connectivity IBM hybrid Cloud
mesh automates the process management
and observability
of application connectivity in and
between public and private clouds this
helps modern Enterprises operate their
infrastructure across hybrid multicloud
and heterogeneous
environments the technology collab
between IBM and equinex will enable
hybrid Cloud mesh customers to take
advantage of the extensive equinex
infrastructure footprint to choose where
to deploy and connect their Enterprise
applications in a flexible and efficient
way to learn more about this exciting
new partnership check out the blog in
the description of this
video next up the Biden Administration
recently released its plan for
implementing the highly anticipated
National cyber security strategy and the
response from experts has been very
positive The New National cyber security
strategy implementation plan outlined
two main areas of emphasis for the
nation's cyber security first is the
need for more capable actors to Bear
more responsibility for cyber security
and second is the need to increase
incentives to invest in long-term
resilience at a higher level the
national cyber security strategy
implementation plan is based on five
core pillars pillar one is defending
critical infrastructure pillar two is
disrupting and dismantling threat actors
pillar three is shaping Market forces
and driving security and resilience
pillar four is investing in a resilient
future and pillar five is forging
International Partnerships to pursue
shared goals to learn more about the
cyber security plan and its response hit
the link
below to finish things up today we are
excited to announce that IBM security
qar Sim has been selected as the winner
of the cyber security breakthrough
Awards Sim solution provider of the year
the evaluation criteria for the awards
program revolve around Innovation it
seeks to honor Solutions and companies
that Stand Out by addressing genuine
needs solving complex problems and
revolutionizing their respective markets
or Industries Q radar Sims recognition
can be attributed to distinctive
features and capabilities that
differentiate it from the other
competitors in this category including
Advanced machine learning and user
Behavior analytics detection of Insider
threats and risky user behavior and
streamlined log Source management to
learn more about the award and Q radar
Sim hit the link
below thanks so much for joining me
today for this episode of IBM Tech now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics I've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video and again please don't
forget to subscribe to our channel to
stay up toate on what's going on in Tech
now